- Thanks a lot for this very
nice introduction as usual.
And I'm impressed by the
level you already put in that.
So you've been explaining
quite a few things already.
That's excellent.
And so I'm thankful for
everybody at Radcliffe,
all the staff, everybody there.
It's really a wonderful place
to have years to rest and change
our minds.
It has been a great
time for me so far,
and I'm really looking
forward to it the coming year.
So I'm here in Radcliffe to
work on the topic of gene
regulation and gene expression.
It's a very broad
topic, vast topic
that touch on very
many things in biology.
I would just take
one angle today just
to give you one example of my
research in this area today.
So first, I'd like to
start by acknowledgments.
Some of the work
I've been presenting
has been done in collaboration
with Frederic Fyon, who
was a PhD in my lab.
He now did finish his PhD.
And much of what I
will be talking about
is taken from the PhD
and some other work
with some collaborator
mentioned here.
So today my talk
here to you is you've
got to take it like
a desert, right?
We are here to understand
new things perhaps.
I know that most of
you are not biologists,
who I will have to provide a lot
of background material for you
to understand my point.
So what I can promise
is that it will
be a certified organic
evolution, the dessert, that it
will be completely free, of
course, of creation modified
ideas.
But, you know, there will
be real bits of theory
into that talk.
And so it might become at
times a little more difficult,
so I will warn you
when it is the case.
And it's a new flavor.
It's new research, something
that has not been presented
so far or in different parts.
So one of the-- an important
puzzle in modern biology
is the question,
why eukaryotic gene
regulation is so overwired?
So I will explain
many of those terms.
So here on that picture
you see the gene network
and the regulatory
networks of the genes
in yeast that have been
depicted with a different set
of functions in
different colors.
And it's really a
huge complexity.
And it's very
difficult to not only
to understand what
is going on, but also
to understand how it came
about in the first place.
Why is it that you've got so
complex regulatory networks
in eukaryotes especially?
So that's my question today.
And the answer is, and all my
talk is just in that slide.
So I will just spend my talk
to explain this slide to you.
So it says that in
prokaryotes the haploids--
I will explain the terms.
Just you've got an overview now.
And you got simple regulation.
In eukaryotes you've got
meiotic sex and recombination.
So I'm seeing an
[INAUDIBLE] that Judy
mentioned in the introduction.
And you've got also diploidy
and, therefore, complex
regulation.
So the red arrows
here are intended
to mean a causal relationship.
And so I won't explain
all those arrows today.
I will mainly explain
this one and this one.
And I will, of course,
give you some background
to understand what
it's all about.
So we've got to start
with the background part
about what natural
selection is all about.
And you probably know.
Most of you, I'm sure, know
about Darwinian evolution
and about natural selection.
The principle of natural
selection is pretty simple.
When you want to understand
why a trait has evolved then
you've got to
understand three things.
That you've got trait variation,
which is brought by mutation.
That this trait
variation is heritable,
inherited through generations.
And that you've got differential
reproduction or survival
of individuals carrying
those mutations.
And that's it.
That's pretty simple.
That's just the core
of Darwinian theory.
And here you've got the Gary
Larson explanation of it,
that shortsightedness is
probably not something
you would expect to evolve.
So that's the first principle.
And you know-- everybody,
I'm sure, knows about it.
The second principle is that
perhaps on longer timescales,
like on what we
call macroevolution,
you've got some other
steps going on, right?
Perhaps rare events
mess things up,
like the extinction of
dinosaurs and things like that.
So here Gary Larson is perhaps
not as good in the explanation,
but you get the point.
So that's-- most
people, non-biologists,
not evolutionary biologists,
that's what they would see what
evolution theory is about.
And you may wonder,
well, is that all?
You know, it looks
pretty simple.
You've got very
little principle,
and yet you've got to
explain biodiversity.
You've got so much to explain.
All these life forms,
it's possible to predict
them and all this diversity and
complexity just from this very
simple principle.
And in fact here I quote
a very famous philosopher
who had this quote about this.
So Wittgenstein had this
quote in a correspondence
to a friend.
"I have always thought
that Darwin was wrong.
His theory doesn't account for
all of this variety of species.
It hasn't the necessary
multiplicity."
And in some sense you may argue
with Wittgenstein about this,
and I will do that.
But you know, it looks
difficult perhaps at first sight
that a very simple process
like natural selection
would give rise to
complexity or diversity.
Then of course,
natural evolution
is not just about those small
processes of natural selection.
It's also a big
historical thing, right?
So that's the history
of Earth from here.
And life on Earth, it takes,
like, billions of years,
you've got many, many events.
And so the question
is, is it really
possible to build an
evolutionary theory that
would account for that?
And from such a simple
principle you might think,
well, perhaps it's
a difficult task.
And in fact, this
problem probably
expands beyond
evolutionary biology.
Is it possible to make
a theory about history?
I know we've got
historians in the audience.
And it's a big
question whether we
could have a theory
about history
or just to explain things,
or perhaps just see history
as Shakespeare did in Macbeth.
If life is just a tale
told by an idiot, full
of sound and fury, signifying
nothing, just trying
to emphasize the idea
that history is just
a matter of chance, a
chance of many events.
But there is not much
to explain beyond that.
And so these are very
important critiques
of evolutionary theory.
And but at the same time, so
we will come to those points
as you will see.
So the questions here are,
is it possible to build
a historical theory?
Is it possible to understand
events in the very deep past?
Can evolutionary theory explains
multiplicity or complexity?
And in fact, many people
have been working on that.
And you know when you talk
about this in general,
you talk about
major transitions.
Major transitions, here a
picture again by Gary Larson--
he's a very useful cartoonist--
where you see when you've
got evolution out of water.
That probably is the
kind of transition people
think about when you
think major transitions.
But they are not
transitions that are really
difficult to understand
or the transitions
that people are working on in
evolutionary biology today.
Those are not very
theoretically challenging.
In fact, the major
transitions in evolution
were put forward by this book,
a very famous book in the field,
about 20 years ago,
trying to explain
what are those big
transitions that we
need to explain in evolution.
And you've got different kinds.
The first type of transitions
are about becoming of groups.
So when you go from
solitary individuals
to new higher-level individuals
through group formation.
For instance, you go
from a unicellular
to a multicellular organism,
this type of change.
That's not the type of change
that we'll be talking about.
The second type
of big transition
is about energy, where
you switch to use
different kinds of energy.
[INAUDIBLE] the story of Earth.
And the last type of transition
is about genetic systems.
That's the type of
thing I'm working on.
And this type of
transition involves
things like sex, recombination
meiosis, diploidy.
I will explain some of those
terms and the central dogma.
The central dogma, you
perhaps heard about it.
It was put forward by Crick
through the discovery of DNA.
And the logic is
that information
flow in biological systems
from DNA to RNA to proteins,
as the blue arrow here.
And this central
dogma is about what
is this flow of information.
And you may ask how did that
structure, that genetic system,
came about in the first place.
And that's where the topic of
gene regulation comes in here.
Because gene regulation
is [INAUDIBLE] genes are
on the DNA, and regulation
because they produce--
well, you've got this protein
production, and that all you
regulate those steps.
That's what is gene regulation
and gene expression.
So that's my topic today.
And as you will see, it's
connected to the other problem
for genetic systems.
So briefly so that we can
see where we are in history,
so we are, like, two
billion years ago,
like the original eukaryotes.
Eukaryotes, that's cells
with nuclei, is about here.
Eukaryotes are pretty
much everything you know,
every big organisms you
know, plants, fungi, animals.
Everything but microbes
are eukaryotes.
And so we are here
interested in understanding
the evolution of gene regulation
in eukaryotes in comparison
to in prokaryotes.
Of course, the
origin of eukaryotes
itself is a very
complex subject.
I will not be going into that.
So that's a prokaryotic cell
and the eukaryotic cells
differ in many, many ways.
So you've got kind
of a basic type
of list of differences between
prokaryotes and eukaryotes.
But their DNA, naked or
not, circular or linear,
but the presence of organelles
and mitochondria in particular.
The reproduction
is very different.
And that's something I
would like you to remember.
So in eukaryotes
you've got meiosis.
I will explain in a minute.
And eukaryotes also
are diploids, which
is not the case in prokaryotes.
So that's a typical
lifecycle of a eukaryote.
You've got that this is how
sex works in eukaryotes.
You've got two events,
meiosis and fertilization.
So that's the two key
events that you find
in all eukaryotic life cycles.
And meiosis is so you've got
these two events, key events,
separate the life cycle into
two parts, the haploid phase
and the diploid phase.
So in the diploid, so we
are diploids in this room,
we have two copies
of a gene, right?
That's one from the father,
one from your mother.
You are a diploid.
So that's the individual
in this phase.
Then you've got this phase here
where the gametes are haploid,
right?
A little warning.
Here at meiosis,
you've got this process
that Judy mentioned, very
important that you've
got recombination at that step.
At that step when
gametes are produced,
then the chromosomes
cross over to produce
a diversity of combination
that is called recombination.
So the next important
difference between prokaryote
and eukaryote is that the gene
regulation is very different.
This one is pretty simple.
This one is very complex.
So how complex it is?
So that's how it works.
So you've got here
a eukaryotic cell.
That's the nucleus.
You've got the DNA.
The DNA is tightly packed
by proteins in [? stones. ?]
Then it opens up.
Then you've got what is
called transcription,
where you've got
some RNA produced
which is not matured yet.
Then you've got RNA processing
export into the cytoplasm.
Then this RNA is
translated into protein.
And you've got a
polypeptide here
which then becomes a protein
after post-translational
modifications.
At each of those
steps, you can have
regulation of gene expression.
Each of those steps.
By various mechanisms.
I won't have time to
detail all of them.
Here I will mostly
focus on the initiation
of transcription, the
major step here where
you go from DNA to RNA.
So it looks like
this in the cell.
So imagine this is a chromosome.
So that's DNA.
You've got a gene here.
Next to that gene you've
got a regulatory sequence,
it's called promoter.
At that site, you've
got an enzyme,
which is called RNA polymerase.
It's just an enzyme
that will produce RNA
from the DNA template.
And the way this enzyme
is attracted to that place
really depends on a lot of
other proteins and factors
that gather here
and make a complex.
And this complex,
in fact, depends
on what is called
enhancers other location
a little further away
on the chromosome that
controls the attraction
to those cofactors.
And basically what differs for
the gene regulation for gene A
or gene B is that the identity,
the sequence of those enhancers
differ mostly.
The next thing you've
got to understand
about gene regulation
in eukaryotes
is that you've got two kinds.
What is called
the cis-regulation
and trans-regulation.
So that you are in a diploid.
You've got this gene,
which is in two copies.
So in yellow here, you've got
the cis-acting sequence, so,
like, the promoter
or the enhancer, that
will control the expression
level of that gene.
And the control
will be, in part,
due to trans-acting
factors, that
is molecules that float
around in the nucleus that
will bind to the sequence.
So but the important
point is that if you've
got a molecule floating
around, it can bind here.
It can also bind here.
So tran-acting factors, they
act on both chromosomes.
Whereas cis-acting factors
just only act on the gene
they are sitting next to.
That's the only
but very important
difference between
the two things.
So now you know
more or less what
is a prokaryote, what is an
eukaryote, that the eukaryote
have meiotic sex.
So we can start, right?
That was the introduction.
I will start by
explaining this arrow.
Why from when you've got
diploid [INAUDIBLE] meiotic sex,
you have diploidy evolving.
So why are we diploids?
Before I get to
that point, you've
got to understand a
very important feature
of diploid genetics.
So in diploids-- well,
in haploids as well.
But when you've got mutations,
most mutations are deleterious.
And we all have a lot of
deleterious mutations.
Every organism carry a load
of deleterious mutations.
And it's very important
to understand that when
a mutation occurs--
then let's say you've got
an allele as a gene, which
is big A. Then let's say you got
a deleterious mutation, little
a, arising in the population.
So you've got three
types of individuals.
The aa.
Aa, and AA.
That's called the heterozygotes
and the homozygotes.
And so that's the three
types of genotypes.
And here if you represent
fitness, or fitness
as a measure of
evolutionary success,
then you can say
that as a reference
the AA has a fitness of
1, and that the presence
of the deleterious allele
at that gene decreases
the fitness of that
individual by a quantity
s when it is homozygote.
So when you are in a
heterozygote individual,
the effect of the mutation
is then 1 minus hs.
And h is called the
dominance of that mutation.
And, in fact, dominance
of deleterious mutation
has been measured in a huge
variety of organisms and cases
and situations and genes.
And deleterious mutation
tend to be recessive,
meaning that h is
below one half.
And in fact, it's about
0.25, one quarter,
on average across many studies.
So the presence of the
deleterious mutation
in population cause what
is called a genetic load.
So in the haploid
population, imagine
you've got deleterious mutation
occurring at the rate u.
Then you've got these
two alleles, Aa.
This one has an
effect on fitness of 1
minus s as I was
just explaining.
In diploids you've got
twice as many mutations
because you've got
twice as much DNA.
And you've got the fitness of
just explain the produce slide.
So now you can compute
what the frequency
of the deleterious mutation
should be in the population.
And as an approximation,
the frequency
of the deleterious
mutation is about U over s
in an haploid population,
and is about 2U over hs.
H is dominant in the
diploid population.
So it means that that's the
frequency at which you'll
find those mutations.
Now you may want to
ask, but what reduction
of fitness overall, on
average in the population
is caused by the presence of
those deleterious mutations?
So well, that's just the
frequency of those mutations
times their effect.
So if you multiply
their effect--
and here they are mostly
found as heterozygote
because they are rare--
you'll find this
very famous results.
In fact, it goes back
to almost a century
now, that the
genetic load, meaning
the reduction, the fitness
reduction in the population,
due to deleterious
mutation, just
depends on the mutation rate.
And it's twice as
big in diploids
because you've got two
times, twice as many genes.
So it is not dependent on
the intensity of selection
on those deleterious alleles.
So because this load is
twice as large in diploids,
meaning that you know the
average fitness of diploids
should be lower all the time
than the average fitness
of haploids, you
may think, well,
why did diploids evolve
in the first place
if their average fitness
is lower than haploids?
Well, that's a
difficult problem.
And in fact, to understand
what's going on we've
got to turn to something
you probably know.
You know that story
about the selfish gene.
You probably heard about
it as a popular idea
popularized by Richard Dawkins.
Just meaning that to understand
what's going on in evolution,
you've got to think about not
only in terms of individuals
like the usual Darwinian way
is all about, but also in terms
of genes.
And so that's just a
way to look at things.
No, there is no difference.
And it may offer clear
insights, but it's just
a matter of perspective.
And so we're going to
practice that this afternoon
a little bit.
So to practice we
make a little model.
We imagine you've
got the same gene
as before with the same
fitness effect, the same story.
And now you think that
there is another gene.
And this other gene
changes in the life cycle
how much time you
spend in the diploid
or in the haploid phase.
That's all it does.
And you wonder will that
gene increase in frequency
or will it decrease in
frequency in the population.
Meaning will it evolve--
or diploidies will
evolve or haploidy will evolve.
That's the way you
solve that problem.
And if you do that, so you've
got this [INAUDIBLE] model.
And they recombine-- you've got
recombination between the two
genes at the rate R. When you
analyze this model, that's
the result. That's
the recombination
rate between the two loci.
And that's the dominance
of the mutation.
I told you that the dominance
of the deleterious mutation
is about one quarter,
so about here.
And so if recombination
is quite high,
so that is if you
are in this red area,
and that's where most
eukaryotic organisms are,
you'd expect diploidy to evolve.
Despite the fact that it reduces
mean fitness in the population.
That's perhaps-- that
there is a trick.
So what's the trick?
So I can put up an equation.
Of course it won't
explain to you the trick.
So I will try to use
metaphors, of course,
to explain to you the result.
Well, the first
metaphor is the metaphor
you've got a double-edged sword.
You've got two problems here.
The first problem,
the first edge,
is that it's good to mask
deleterious mutations.
When you are a
diploid, you don't
feel the deleterious
mutation as hard
just because they are
masked, because they
are partially recessive.
So perhaps it's a good thing.
At the the same time, if these
mutations are masked and hidden
to selection, you know they will
accumulate in the population.
So perhaps it's not
such a good thing.
But you've got to
weigh those two ideas.
So how do you do?
Well, that's where the
second metaphor comes in.
And that's where we try to
practice the selfish gene idea.
So imagine that for a minute
you are a selfish gene causing
a little bit more of diploidy.
And you arrive in a population
where you've got only haploids.
What's going on?
Well, first you
enter a population
because you've got haploids
where deleterious mutations are
very efficiently purged
out of the population.
So it's quite a
nice place to be.
Not so many deleterious
mutations around.
And if you are unlucky
enough to have,
to be associated with such
a deleterious mutation,
it's not a big deal either
because precisely you
are a diploid.
You are a diploid
individual because you
are a gene causing diploidy.
As a consequence, you
don't feel the effect
of that mutation too hard.
It's not such a bad thing.
But this mutation will not be
weeded out of the population
because you are
a diploid, right?
The trick is that if
recombination is large enough,
this deleterious mutation
which is still around--
no, it was not eliminated
in the population--
will be a burden to
everyone in the population.
Not only in you as a
gene causing diploidy.
So what's going on, in fact--
because recombination,
you know re-sort genes.
So what's going on is that you
enjoy the benefit of masking
the deleterious mutation.
But you share the cost
with everybody else
in the pollution.
It's no surprise that
such a strategy evolves.
Oh, there was a
part of the talk.
There was another
part like that.
So that's where you
probably get the idea what
is the selfish gene
idea is all about.
You start thinking a little
bit more clearly about what's
going on when you take
the perspective of a gene
to exist off that.
Even if it's just a device that
you use to make things clear.
Of course, the
third metaphor here
is that natural
selection here is not
optimizing average
fitness in the population.
So on average, you
know the fitness
in the population
across [INAUDIBLE]
is reduced by natural selection.
So if you like the invisible
hand of natural selection,
to take an economical
metaphor, it's
not maximizing average fitness.
And that's something
that you've got
to remember about most
situation about evolution.
It's not so simple.
Summary of this first part.
If there is recombination
in the population,
if deleterious mutation are
at least partially recessive,
then it follows that
diploidy is favored.
Meaning that if you consider
a gene that extends diploidy,
it will prevail.
And this evolution is
to lower average fitness
of the population.
But that's a side effect.
So when you've
got recombination,
you evolve diploidy.
Well, now I'm trying
to-- will try and spend
the last of the part
of the talk to explain
to you the relationship
between diploidy and complex
regulation.
So the evolution of gene
regulation in diploids.
So we go back to
diploid expression.
So here again we've got
a gene with two alleles
with deleterious mutation.
We've got a cis-acting
regulator in yellow
and a trans-acting factor.
And they contribute to produce
proteins, some of which
are green because they are
produced from that allele.
Some are blue because they
are produced from that allele.
And they are kind of roughly
producing the same amount.
Because they've got the same
regulatory sequence in this.
Now, what's going on
if you've got mutation
in the cis-regulatory sequence?
Imagine you've got a
cis-acting factor which
is a little bit more efficient
at attracting the transcription
factors, like this or here.
If this stronger--
let's call it stronger--
cis-regulator is close
to the allele, little a,
then you will produce more
of little a protein, more
of the green protein.
If this cis-regulator
is stronger,
the stronger cis-regulator
is close to the big A,
then you will produce
more of the blue protein.
And not 50/50.
And in fact, when people
go out and measure
in using transcriptomics
for instance,
almost you've got imbalance
between expression,
in allelic expression,
you'll find a lot.
So that's an example
where quite old studies,
early days of transcriptomics,
where you got nearly half
of the genes where
you've got more
than a two-fold difference
in the expression
level between the two
[INAUDIBLE] allele.
So now you've got to think
about the same thing,
but in terms of what are
the consequences on fitness
for the individual?
So imagine as before
that the little a
is a deleterious mutation.
Then if you produce more of the
deleterious mutation, of course
the fitness would be reduced.
And if you produce
less of it, then it
would be a little higher.
So in effect, variation
in the cis-regulator
will cause a variation in the
dominance of that mutation.
So dominance here would
be a little bit higher.
And here it will be
a little bit lower.
So you want to ask,
if you've got this--
if you've got mutation
on those sequences,
then you will have
allele-specific expression.
Then you would have
changes in the dominance.
So what are the evolutionary
consequences of that?
So we go back to this
expression to fitness graph,
where here imagine you've got
the fraction of expression
of this little a.
So where you
[INAUDIBLE] heterzygote,
you still reproduce
50/50 of each protein.
Then you've got the same as
before, a dominance of h.
If the stronger
cis-regulator is close
to the deleterious
mutation, then you
will produce a little
bit more of that protein.
And therefore the fitness
would be a little bit more
reduced because you've got more
of that deleterious mutation--
of that defective
protein, sorry.
So that's the 2 value.
Because this
function is concave,
you've got this property
which is inevitable
that you've got the average
of those two dominance
here will be larger than the
h values you started with.
That is a detail you
will see later perhaps.
And next, you do a model as
we did for the diploidy case.
You put exactly the
same ingredient.
You've got deleterious mutation,
then you've got the fitness.
And you introduce a new allele
that causes a little bit more
of expression or less.
And you see what's going
on, what's the outcome.
So if you look at the outcome
for a weaker cis-regulator,
that's the result. That's
the log recombination
is the distance between
cis-regulator and the gene.
In logs, so meaning that it's
very close to the gene here
and it's quite far here.
And that's a
neutral expectation.
So that's a way that's a way to
measure evolutionary success.
You compare the fate
of an allele that's
reducing the population in
one copy, to the probability
of fixation of an allele which
is neutral, does nothing.
And you compare the two.
If the fixation is
lower than neutral,
it means it's selected against.
When it's above neutrality,
it means it's favored.
So as you can see here, the
cis-regulator is always weaker.
A weaker cis-regulator
is always disfavored.
In contrast, a
stronger cis-regulator
is always favored
except when it's
too far away from the gene in
terms of recombination here.
So stronger enhancers,
stronger cis-regulator
are always favored if they
are close enough to their gene
that they regulate.
Of course, you've got a lot of
models you can do about this.
And again, the metaphorical
explanation of what's going on
is simply that you've got--
as in the diploidy model,
you've got two effects.
One of masking and
one of purging.
The masking effect is always--
so it's always a bad thing
to have a new cis-regulator
in the population,
because it increases
average dominance.
These mutations
are more exposed,
are more visible to selection.
It reduces mean
fitness of individual.
But stronger enhancers,
stronger cis-regulator,
then you know they will--
the gene that sits
next to them will
be more visible to selection,
more exposed to selection.
And therefore better purged
from deleterious mutation.
And so on average those
stronger regulators
will find themselves always
on good genetic background,
if you like.
And that's the
reason they spread.
And in fact, they spread
indefinitely in this model.
There is what is
called a runaway.
There is no reason, except
if you put it in the model,
that this process will stop.
It will go forever.
Cis-regulator will go further--
increasing strength further
and further and further.
There is no limit,
at least f model.
But it's like you run and you
keep staying at the same place.
Because diploidy did not change,
dominance did not change.
After the spread of a
stronger cis-regulator,
you are back to
the same situation
where you've got
50/50 expression,
deleterious mutation
of the same effect.
Everything's the same
except that you've
got constant evolution on
this cis-regulatory region.
And of course, the
strength of cis-regulator
you can see in different--
it can be different things.
It can be that
the sequence where
you've got the matching between
the cis-regulatory region
and the transcription
factor [INAUDIBLE]..
It can also be that you've got a
duplication of those sequences,
or that these sequences start to
attract different transcription
factor just to
increase in strength.
Of course you may think,
well, but if the strength
of cis-regulator
increases and increases,
perhaps it pushes
expression levels up.
And perhaps that's
not such a good thing.
If you've got a
stronger cis-regulator,
perhaps you push
too many proteins,
and perhaps that's
not a good thing.
And in fact, when
you model this,
so you introduce the
idea that if you depart
from an optimal
quantity of protein
produced you've got
a fitness penalty--
so that the optimal
production of a protein
and that the expression you
achieve, if it's too large
then it's not good, if it's
too low, it's not good either.
And you can introduce other loci
that contribute to expression,
total expression.
So I will just give you
a very brief example
where a second locus is another
cis-regulatory sequence.
In that case, I'll
just jump here.
So you introduce the first
cis-regulator at that point
here.
So it reached some
value and it stops
because expression level
increased too much,
and it's deleterious.
At that point, you introduce
mutation on the second locus.
And what's going on is that
they each evolve in combination
to compensate each other.
So you've got co-evolution
of all the regulators
together so that the expression
level stays the same.
Yet you've got
permanent and very quick
evolution of all
those sequences.
So that's summary of part II.
If there is diploidy,
if deleterious mutation
are partially recessive,
then cis-regulator
evolve in a runaway fashion
that triggers co-evolution
of other regulators.
And so regulatory
complexity emerges
selectively and not because
of individual advantage here.
Though we are done
with that slide,
so I jump to my conclusions.
First, this theory-- in
fact, I didn't have time
to explain all the
other theories that
were [INAUDIBLE] around
about the evolution
of evolutionary complexity.
Most of which can be summarized
by saying that complexity
is more maladaptive,
is just arising
in small populations
because of the fixation
of deleterious mutations.
So this theory
here is not at all
about this fixation, this
maladaptive complexity.
It's not really an adaptive
in the Darwinian sense
that you've got an optimization
of some individual level
properties.
But it's Darwinian--
you've got selection here
just because you've got
genes that are favored
and that spread because
of natural selection.
So it associates diploidy
and regulatory complexity
explicitly, explaining
perhaps better
why you find this
regulatory complexity
in eukaryotes and not in
prokaryote, which are haploid.
And it emphasizes
genetic conflicts
as a major engine of evolution.
It results in just [INAUDIBLE],,
as you could imagine.
So in evolution of
biology we often
use a metaphor of the Red
Queen taken from Lewis Caroll's
book, where now here you see
it takes all the running you
can do to keep in
the same place,
says this Red Queen to Alice.
You think that you've
got to run faster, just
stays in the same place.
Or if you prefer in
movies, everything
needs to change so
everything can stay the same.
It's the same idea.
That you've got here a lot of
evolution which is going on.
But you know, on the surface
at the individual level,
you barely notice.
So if I can sketch
a very quick history
of eukaryotic evolution.
So you first had this
first gene controlled
by cis-regulatory region.
Because of the process
I was explaining,
it increases in
strength, it multiplies.
But a lot of complexity in
the regulatory cis-regulatory
region emerging.
At some point, you go-- you
lack some transcription factor.
There's not enough of
them to go further.
And perhaps you mutate here to
get some new, better strengths
of the cis-regulatory region.
And that's the
point where you've
got the evolution of
this overwired regulation
in eukaryotes.
So here we are, you know,
like one billion years ago.
Of course then you can add
all sorts of consequences
of this process.
And for instance, you can
imagine that the whole region
here is duplicated.
And now you've got two
versions of that gene.
That because you've
got such a complexity
in the regulatory region.
It's fairly easy to
evolve, for instance,
tissue-specific expression where
you just switch off different
cis-regulator in different
tissue so that you've got--
in multicellular
organisms you can
evolve different
tissue and different--
and what is called development.
All right, so that is
what I wanted to say.
I've been explaining
those different arrows.
I'm working on some
more integrated project
here at Radcliffe.
We don't have time to
talk about everything.
And I'll finish by
quoting about, of course,
you know Wittgensten.
I think that you can see that
genetic conflicts can generate
a lot of complexity and
a lot of multiplicities
that you would not
expect if you just
think in terms of kind of naive
Darwinian view of evolution.
Of course it's more difficult
to disagree with Shakespeare.
And I've just put
in green the parts
where I think you can read
a little of what he said.
Thank you.